previously on TV sentence
reading and it's the worst kind of
reading Wikipedia also TV show uses
Wikipedia to confirm birthday statistics
according to Wikipedia studies have
shown that Wikipedia is unreliable from
the reading cometh the title of the show
never mind the first two words are in
the first goddamn sentence but sure how
clever it is to find that is lurking in
the second paragraph there one of the
signs of a great twist is that it seems
obvious in hindsight and this pilot
manages that subtlety perfectly that
plus the incredible Sufjan Stevens song
in the background and I am already
worried the stupid show might actually
be good this is ass suits ah yes ma'am
your birthday suits only one I've got
this is your only suit I bet you're a
hit at weddings and funerals it's my
birthday
and I would really really like to see
the dance look I can enjoy a seductive
pregnancy dance as much as the next guy
while holding a cupcake with a lit
candle the mixing birthday sex with
pregnancy fetishes and flaming sugar
rushes and I fear it might all leave the
house burning down at some point a few
notes on these notes sure this first one
seems helpful but then you just write
bad on some hostess freaking snowballs
I can't tell they're bad for you just by
the fact that they have the word hostess
printed directly on the package and
throw this crap out you know it takes
less time than writing this sentence on
a sticky note and putting it on these
dead lobster leftovers actually throwing
it out and what is this nonsense where
you have written yourself a second note
underneath the first and somehow you're
surprised by this who purposely writes a
follow-up note takes the time to put
them on in the right order and then
somehow forgets the entire
well-thought-out plan also I've used
sticky notes before there's no way
you're pulling one of those things off
at a time also also these notes are
nowhere to be seen when we were first
introduced to this cake a mere 15
seconds ago dear God the man look I know
that's part of the joke but this genius
marketing team couldn't come up with a
better slogan then we're handsome
happens how about something like mondays
come and see if the human male can
actually take care of an infant and for
some reason with a shirt off also here's
an extra sin because the mani is fake
and I'll never feast on the absolute
send buffet that that pilot would have
put in front of me you harass me I bet I
can make that go away there's nothing
you could say my water just broke
yep are you kidding when will you ever
get a chance to have that awesome water
just broke sex again you know and I
think it all went wrong for me
was 1986 second grade they were sending
the Challenger up into space if Kevin is
turning 36
and this show is taking place in the
year it aired which would be 2016 then
Kevin would have been 6 in 1986
depending on what month this is that
would place him in either kindergarten
or first grade in 1986 might not the
second maybe that's how I wound up as
the Manny I'm sure christa mcauliffe
would be happy to know that her death
led to a rich actor being upset that
he's rich and has a successful
television show 36 we're officially a
late thirties like we are deep in the
threes you might say you're 30-something
then huh if only a show had already been
made that took a serious look at life
issues in the 30s with that name the
show would almost seem redundant yeah
well you are a lot smarter than you look
so Michael Bay told me and yet screw you
for mentioning he-who-must-not-be-named
now then I'm dr. Koh Tao ski but you can
call me doc or dr. K or major dad can I
call you major dad really like the call
you made your dad just a general note to
all it's never a good look to be the one
gleefully pointing out who the Jews are
yo me to breastfeed you would that make
you feel better if I breastfed you don't
necessarily have to make me think this
joke is this funny but you do have to
make me think this audience thinks this
joke is this funny and you didn't either
are we suggesting you know that the
Manny thinks a grown man can breastfeed
a baby
Manny hacky I would be excellent at TV
since I know we've gotten pretty lacks
with our definition of kids sports but
if we really arrived to the place where
a league that cared enough to have
uniforms and referees would have coaches
that let their players literally sit in
the middle of the field and braid each
other's hair I submit to you that we
have not sorry for anything I'm gonna
say minutes two hours I mean that event
pregnant mom jokes about becoming a
monster during labor cliche and finally
proved to myself and to you and to my
family who loves me that I didn't need a
thing from you
sterling que rom hey Alan Alan Thicke
cameo Vicky oh why did they even have
Alan sit down if his makeup was finished
and they just needed to remove the paper
from his collar they could have done
that at whatever makeup station he was
at before
true everyone usually has their phone at
the ready these days except not at live
audience recordings like this in fact
they don't even let you take it in the
building I spent five hours one time at
a Big Bang Theory recording and the
security to get in was tighter than
say they did pass around a cheese pizza
about halfway through so we wouldn't
starve though so there's that hey babe I
need you to help Annie with her home so
you're telling me that Randall didn't
even so much as text his wife that he
was bringing home as a strange father to
meet the girls
I catch how if I forget to tell my wife
I'm bringing takeout home let alone a
former drug addict to abandon his
grandchildren path will take care of the
sins okay Randall wait Sally Field yeah
hmm I have a thing for Sally Field
zooming she's like 60 dare you show if
having a thing for Sally Field is
somehow wrong I don't want to be right
let's just say Marisa Tomei wasn't the
first Aunt May to activate my
web-shooters
what that's it what do you mean I mean
you're not gonna invite me in for a
handy or something
this works you want how many calories
are in a sausage seriously I know the
show debuted pre Harvey and all but even
way back in 2016 we knew to at least
wait for a second date before throwing
out the rapey innuendo right watching
videos anywhere other than YouTube and
watching it in a minimized window that's
racist
lower your Lopez we lost the third baby
Jack I'm not very sorry now adding
infant mortality to weight management
job dissatisfaction and child
abandonment as a list of issues this
show wants to cover in the first 30
minutes of its existence this is us is
setting up that it's basically going to
collect every single human trauma it can
find and slather it on to a single
family for our amusement
it's just that I'm I'm dying is all of
course you are to the manufacturer of
Kleenex brand facial tissues grief this
show give me at least five minutes
between cut punches No
what if I'm not better than the Manny
you weren't good enough to keep playing
arrow so strange damn thing someone
looks a newborn on my fire station dun
dun duh it was a story of one family the
whole time I've always wondered what
would happen if M night directed an
episode of Days of Our Lives but now I
know what strange congratulations man
mccrane II knew that's all he would have
to say he could have skipped over
reliving the dead wife and son bit show
continues to really pound home this
twist I think we were good with the
butterfly collars and a little smoking
and hospital thing not sure you needed
the Cronkite us in the face as well Jack
and Rebecca lived by the replaced one
dead kid with another kid rule also
known as the faceoff solution show
completely yada yada is how a hospital
would let a random family just take home
and abandon child not saying it's not
possible I'm just saying you for making
me cry my own tears you beautiful syrupy
all of emotion porn what the why are we
saying anyone can cook tradition is
tradition could this thing possibly
before it's for rectal examinations
rectum damn near killed Oh would that
make you feel better if I breastfed you
I have nipples Greg could you milk me do
you know what my job description is I'm
in acquisitions I look up and I catch
what falls out of the sky where the hell
are you going now in sick let me repeat
I am Alan Thicke
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]